if you're in a situation where you
should do something and the excuses roll
in you only have five seconds before the
excuses win it has to do with how your
brain is designed I started seeing this
five second window
everywhere you walk into a networking
meeting and the five second window is
right there because you look around and
you see all these people you should talk
to and you feel yourself freeze if
you're trying to sell something the five
second wind is always there because you
either have a phone you need to pick up
and make a phone call or you have a
person you need to talk to but instead
of doing it that five second window's
right there and the excuses roll in and
then you're not doing it what's more
sophisticated about it is that you have
two modes to your brain you have the
prefrontal cortex which is the mode of
your brain it's the front part of your
brain that does all your strategic
planning it's what you're using when
you're acting with courage it's what
you're using when you are learning
anything new if you've ever taken a
standardized test when you walk out of a
standardized test what do you have you
have a freaking headache because you've
been using this part of your brain the
other part is the interior part of your
brain which automates everything it's
where self-doubt is it's where habits
are it's where automated decision making
is it's where every negative [ __ ] that
we do it's stuck right here and so the
problem with our excuses if you want to
get into the brain science is that if
you start to think and you start to
think I feel tired or I don't want to or
I'm too stressed out or now's not the
right time that becomes automatic and it
gets encoded right here so part of the
problem with our excuses is that when
you stop and think and hesitate you
trigger your brain to automatically talk
you out of it that's the problem it's
not the excuses it's that your brain has
done it over and over and now it takes
over so I invented the world's most
powerful cheat code for the brain one
night when I was drunk sitting in my
living room watching television need
motivation you better watch a top ten
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Mel Robbins and my take on
her top 50 rules for Success enjoy
in order to make it stick go Brick by
Brick In order to make it stick go Brick
by Brick one of the things that's
interesting about having Big Dreams and
big goals is that oftentimes
the fact that the goals and the dreams
that we have are so big
it makes them uh really really difficult
to achieve because you spend so much
time thinking about how big the idea or
the dream is that you become paralyzed
in the moment around taking action how
do you build a house
by laying a foundation Brick by Brick by
Brick you go one small brick at a time
and it's exactly the same thing for your
goals by the way so if you think about
where you're at in this moment and you
think about the path that will take you
forward to your Big Dreams or to this
change that you want to make and I'm
going to use the eating program as my
example because this is daunting to me I
can come up with a million reasons right
now just like I'm sure you can come up
with a million reasons why you can't run
a marathon you can't do the singing
telegram business you can't take nature
pictures for a living you can't be more
connected to your husband which is what
Leanne wants you can't launch that
aromatherapy business I can't possibly
do a structured eating program with a
scale right now because I travel too
much because I'm too busy because I'm
lazy because I'm not deliberate like my
bracelet remember my my intent bracelet
I'm reminding myself to be deliberate
which is probably why I'm thinking about
this program
the path between where I'm at and where
you want to get to is the same it is a
brick path
and it is comprised of a ton of little
bricks that come together to take me
forward and so when you think about a
goal or you think about a dream as a
million little bricks that come together
and lay a path forward that's the way
visually you can break down your goals
and so for me you know what that one
brick could be today it could be asking
Chris or my uh brother-in-law for the
phone number of the person not even
making the call people I'm talking about
breaking them down to one brick so I
will get that phone number and I will
write it down in my little red book or I
will write it down in my five second
journal and that way I will have the
number and guess what the brick is going
to be tomorrow the brick tomorrow is
going to be to call the guy
right and make an appointment and then
the next brick might be to read a little
bit and so the key is going Brick by
Brick to make it stick because if you
think you can lay the whole path between
where you're at and where you want to go
right now you're nuts I started thinking
about luck because there are for a long
time in my life I started to think that
luck was for other people that luck was
just one of those things that if you
were lucky enough to be born with luck
you won the lottery you got the job you
wanted your family got along and the
truth is there's a tremendous amount of
science behind luck that luck is
something that you can make for yourself
that you can become luckier based on the
things that you do and the things that
you think about and one of the things
about lucky people is a lot of lucky
people make their luck because they have
trained themselves to think
optimistically and one small trick that
you can use in your life that is free
you can do it today is when you go to
bed tonight before you go to sleep I
want you to write down one thing
that happened today that was good that's
it every night before you go to bed I
want you to write down one thing that
happened today that's good in fact let's
do it right now in the comments go to
the comments and tell me one thing that
has happened today that you can think of
that's good just one thing maybe you got
up on time maybe you didn't have traffic
today on the way to work maybe uh you
haven't fought with your kids this
morning maybe you got to the gym maybe
you woke up and for the first hour of
the day you didn't make yourself wrong
all of those things while they're really
little don't dismiss them because those
are things that are good and the reason
why I want you to start a practice where
every night before you go to bed or if
you don't want to do it at night do it
in the morning every night before you go
to bed write down one thing that
happened today that was good the reason
why you're doing this is you are
training yourself to start to spot the
good believe it or not training yourself
to start to look for the good in your
life fundamentally trains your mind away
from looking at the negative so that you
start seeing this thing that's positive
about your life versus that thing that's
negative about your life and the secret
to life and this is so hard to grasp
is to just be yourself that's the secret
there's only one you
there's only ever going to be one you
there's never going to be another you
and the way you make your mark in this
world the way that you learn how to
believe in yourself
the way that you discover the people
that you're supposed to surround
yourself with the job that you or career
path that you're supposed to have
is by being the real also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there now I got fired from a job I was
was really excited about what should I
do excellent question first of all how
many of you have ever been fired from a
job
yep yep I have been fired from a job and
let me tell you something it's a kick in
the teeth doesn't it there is nothing
that feels worse in the moment than
being brought into a conference room and
being let go and then how bad does it
Blow to pack up your stuff and to leave
it stings it is terrible it is
humiliating there is nothing around it
there's nothing around that feeling even
if it's a job that you can't stand even
if it's a job where you've been looking
for another job even if you know in your
heart that this is the biggest blessing
in disguise because he didn't really
like it there you still want to be the
one to rip off the Band-Aid don't you
you want to be the one to walk in and be
like guess what people I found a
different job I'm out of here so when
they beat you to the punch and they tell
you the truth that this isn't working
it's not working for them it's not
working for you and now it's time for
you to leave it is still a kick in the
teeth so I want to be clear about
something feeling down feeling
embarrassed feeling angry about how it
was handled even if they handled it in
the way that it's legal that is normal
it's normal because it blows to be
rejected and that's exactly what happens
to you emotionally when you get fired
from a job I get that because boy oh boy
have I been there I have been fired from
jobs that I actually liked I have been
fired from jobs that I needed and I have
been fired from jobs that I viscerally
hated that I was physically sick going
to work every morning I hated it so much
and it still stinks when you're fired so
here's what I want you to do when you're
fired I want you to really just Relish
in how much it stinks for I don't know
an hour
no more than 24 hours you get to milk
this puppy for free you know a free
dinner from your pals at night you get
to milk this and complain about it to
all your friends for 24 hours and then
guess what you gotta stop complaining
about it you got to stop thinking about
it because you don't have a choice
anymore the job is over and I don't want
you looking back I want you looking
forward now before you look forward
though I want you to do one of the
signature things that we talk about all
the time and what is that
I want you to look for the message in
the mess what is it that you learned
about yourself or about a job or a boss
or a um or a kind of work that you need
to make sure you understand the message
in the mess because when you get the
emotion out of the way guess what you
always see about a job or a breakup
that happens you always see that that
was exactly what was supposed to happen
that that job that that person that that
manager that that Focus that that was
holding you back and you were just too
scared to take the leap you were too
worried about finances you were worried
about how it looked I've been there I
get it but you need to see the message
in the mess because I don't want you to
make the mistake and step into the exact
same thing or the exact same type of job
or the exact same management situation
that didn't work the first time because
part of the reason why jobs don't work
is it's not a fit you see people get
fired for a lot of reasons some of the
reasons why people get fired is because
the companies are not doing well and in
that case you want to thank your lucky
stars that you're getting out now so
that you can find something better if
it's not a fit
that's a more nuanced reason to get
fired but let me tell you something if
it's not a fit for the company it wasn't
a fit for you either and so look for the
message in the mess what are you going
to learn about this situation whether
there was a skill Gap
and you need to bring your skills up to
speed so that you're not floundering
your next job or maybe it was a
personality Gap that you accepted
something that in your heart you knew
wasn't right but you took it because you
had to or because you felt insecure
don't make that mistake again you know
that
um wave that you feel or your tongue
gets numb or you get tightness in your
cheeks or you freeze you know when that
happens based on the science
there is only a 90-second chemical
release in your body it's called the
90-second rule when your body starts to
stomach starts to flutter when your
heart starts to race when you feel this
feeling of fear that you have that's
unique to you based on the science
there's a 90-second rule and all of the
chemical release that's happening
because your body is going into a state
of being alert it only
sticks around for 90 seconds
as long as you don't let your thoughts
race if your thoughts start to race
you'll start to agitate the situation so
the next time that your body goes into a
state of alert stomach gets tight you
feel Frozen you get stuck you feel your
neck when the body starts to do that
number one
just remember it means your body is
getting ready to be alert and pay
attention does it and it does not mean
you're going to lose control it does not
mean you're in danger it does not mean
to stop or to shut up
I want you to take a deep breath
count to five five four three two one
that's it and realize that the hormones
that just got released because you're
about to do something
they only last 90 seconds that's it you
can breathe slowly you can count to 90.
you can get up and walk around you can
do 90 seconds of jumping jacks you can
meditate for 90 seconds you can ground
your feet in your chair and wiggle a
minute so that you feel your body in
your chair
foreign
and what you're going to find is that
you're going to be blown away you're
going to be blown away because what
you're going to see is that in 90
seconds flat you can go from being
somebody who has an upset stomach and
who would normally not go talk to your
boss who would normally not walk into
that gym who would normally not make
that call
in 90 seconds flat you can manipulate
your body state to calm down and you
will notice that your thoughts do not
race your thoughts calm down you're in
full control and now you can speak up
and now you can show up the truth is if
you want control in your life if you
want to make things happen you have to
be able to expect that you're going to
get a no and do it anyway so what do I
mean when I say if you want control
expect to know
well there's a couple things that I mean
by it number one if you're somebody that
gets paralyzed because you want things
to be perfect
perfectionism is a way that most of us
try to handle or mitigate or make sure
that we don't hear no we assume that if
we're perfect everything's going to go
okay and so we spend all of our energy
thinking about our dating profile or
thinking about the business plan or
thinking about how to make things
perfect and the reason why we do that is
we're terrified to hear no we're
terrified to put something out there
that's not perfect because if it's not
perfect you might get a no
um one of the better ways to handle this
is to actually expect a no you know I
saw the most incredible quote by our
friend faustina
over in Australia she's very famous DJ
and friend of ours from Australia and
she put up the most amazing quote and
I'm going to get it totally wrong
um but it's something like this
you have to be yourself
because
how else are the people who are looking
for you gonna find you and I think
particularly when it comes to dating
what we tend to do is we are so afraid
of being rejected by anybody out there
that we try to be somebody that we're
not that we put out a fake improved or
what we think is improved version of
ourselves in order to not hear no and
most of us pretend to be somebody that
we're not When We Fear rejection when we
believe that how we are who we are isn't
good enough and so that's why it's so
important for you to understand that you
have to be willing to hear a no you have
to be willing to hear a no from the
wrong people so that the people that are
looking for you can find you so that the
people who want to be part of your
business can be part of your business if
you're putting a fake person out there
or a pretend perfect person out there
because you think that's gonna that's
gonna save you from rejection
you're actually screwing yourself over
here's your new definition of passion
passion is simply energy that's all that
it is okay
passion is what you feel when you are
energized and excited about what you're
doing okay I want you to think about
that for a minute I want you to think
about a moment in time when you felt
incredibly passionate about something
okay and why don't you in the comments
tell me where are you watching from and
tell me about a moment in time when you
felt incredibly passionate about what
you were doing about where you were
about the people that you were with
describe that moment for me because when
you start to really investigate
passion is energy this is what you're
going to discover those moments when you
are super passionate like I'm sure my
kids would write down when they're doing
community theater with all their friends
I would write down whenever I'm doing
any kind of creative project with my
team I'm incredibly energized whenever
I'm doing group exercise stuff climbing
a mountain doing a 5K race doing some
sort of walkathon I'm incredibly
energized by that whenever I'm
um doing some sort of creative project
incredibly energized by that whenever
I'm working with our video team
incredibly energized by that whenever I
am coaching someone or giving advice I
am incredibly energized by that and so
what I want you to understand is that if
you look back on your life you have had
moments where you have felt passion I'm
being very deliberate in how I'm talking
this morning on coffee talk because
passion is a huge topic for so many of
you and you've been so focused on trying
to figure out what job is going to make
me uh passionate what job is my passion
what is my purpose on the earth I'm
going to tell you what your purpose on
Earth is right now your purpose on Earth
is to figure out how to align your life
so that you feel more energized and
excited by it that's it and it begins
with you following the energy and
following your natural enthusiasm you're
not going to think your way to Passion
you can't think your way to finding
something that you feel in your heart it
doesn't work that way you got to feel
your way into it it's inside of you do
you understand there's no passion out
there somewhere the passion is in here
and so what you have to do first is
you've got to stop thinking that you're
going to find it somewhere and you've
got to realize that passion is about
unlocking something that's already
already in you my mind can be my worst
enemy I was laying in bed last night and
I had fallen asleep and I kept waking up
and you know what I was thinking about I
was waking up because I could hear
people in the hallway kind of coming in
from a late night of partying and you
know what the first thing that my mind
defaulted to
there being a fire in the hotel and I
started having these visions of my
daughter and I going down the stairwell
and getting trapped and then I had
visions of us being on the balcony on
this room and fire kind of engulfing and
what are we doing are we tying a rope
wish I mean it's just Insanity absolute
insanity and I
I use the techniques that I teach you I
went 54321 I am not thinking about this
and the thought disappeared because I
constantly reset my mindset and you know
one of the reasons why I'm telling you
this is if you are tired of feeling
negative if you feel often that your own
thoughts are the things that trip you up
in life that you wish that your mind
were more positive I'm telling you that
I'm the same way just because I teach
this stuff just because I study this
just because I do what I do for a living
doesn't make me immune to what it means
to be human and what it means to be
human is that your brain and your body
want you to survive your brain and your
body remember situations that scare the
Daylights out of you your brain and your
body try to talk you out of anything
that makes you feel risky and your brain
given that it has been
um trained by situations in the past and
given that you allow it to worry all the
time you have a habit of doing it if
you're not careful and you're not
deliberate your brain will default to
scary crap like mine was last night that
doesn't mean you you're broken it means
that your brain is thinking something
that's broken and it's time for you to
reset your mindset and pull it back do
you know what the one
strategy
one strategy that is associated with
making more money
for women do you know if there's what is
one strategy
that will help you make more money as a
woman when you work in a company
you can put it in the comments you can
guess
I know it's not working longer hours no
it's not taking the notes in the meeting
no it's not um doing everybody else's
work for them the one strategy based on
Research that will actually translate to
you making more money is making sure
your achievements are known
and I want to dig deeper into this
because there are two kinds of work
right two kinds of work I want you to
shift your Paradigm in the way that you
think about work because you do two
kinds of work you do work that is
visible and that is the work that you
get credit for so visible work consists
of the ideas that you share in a meeting
it consists of the things that you talk
to your boss about it consists of the
work that you're doing that people see
it consists of the results that you
generate that are reported and discussed
and most importantly it consists of the
projects that you are working on that
are strategically aligned with the goals
of the company that people know about
invisible work on the other hand is all
the stuff you don't get credit for so
all those folks that you Mentor in
private you're not getting credit for
that you should still do it but I'm
going to tell you how to do it
differently
um answering the same question over and
over and over again for multiple people
on telephone calls that's invisible and
if you only make one change this year in
your career I want you to take on a
habit of making sure your
accomplishments are known that the
things that you're doing are more
visible the most important thing hang
out with people that cheer for you this
is so important I don't like I can't say
this enough
behavior is contagious they have proven
this they have proven this Google the
Framingham study it was a really famous
heart study that was done where they
looked at human behavior over what's
called a longitudinal study which
basically means they studied people for
a number of years and they found that
you catch the behavior of other people
if you hang out with smokers over time
your objection to smoking lowers because
you're hanging out with smokers and you
become socialized to it and you are more
likely to smoke if you hang out with
happier people if you hang out with
people that are more successful than you
if you hang out with people that run all
the time guess what happens you become
socialized to those positive behaviors
the fastest way to make a behavior
change is to hang out with people that
are positive that are cheering for you
that are up to cool stuff that are so
busy and engaged in their life they
don't have time for passive aggressive
[ __ ] because they're busy building
something and being appreciative and
that's who you should hang out with what
do you do when you feel overwhelmed
because your home life your work life
your side hustle trying to take care of
yourself
you can't find the time what I always do
is I always come back to the basics when
you tip into overwhelm go back to the
basics start with a morning routine I
know the second that I am in overwhelm
which I am right now I have lost the
discipline of having a consistent
morning routine I still wake up without
my phone I still don't look at my phone
I haven't taken those 30 minutes every
morning for myself to plan my day so I
have been waking up I don't look at my
phone but I go straight for the coffee
I think about what I need to do and
since every single day this week it's
been a speech or a massive meeting
that's taken precedence but I have not
put in the discipline but I talk about
all the time of just taking 30 minutes
to plan what's important to me you know
when you start to say
I have to work on my book
ah I have to do that thing that I need
to do ah I have to pick I have to pick
up my kids oh I got it I have to talk to
switch have to with get to
it's a little word reversal that changes
everything I get to work on the
newsletter this morning
and I get to write something that almost
400 000 people are going to read I get
to work on a book manuscript today as we
fly to Orlando I get to pick up my kids
tomorrow when I land I get to start to
say I get to
because that switch of going I have to
which adds weight and burden switching
it to I get to makes it a privilege
it makes you be grateful about what you
get to do because honestly it is a
privilege whatever it is that you're
doing and when you come from that place
and you think this I get to not that I
have to
um you will bring power to what you get
to do when people are passive aggressive
or they give you fake compliments or
they give you the silent treatment
typically that's fueled out of jealousy
and jealousy is nothing more than an
emotion that people feel when you have
something that they feel they deserve
and a lot of us feel jealousy because
it's easier to be jealous of somebody
and to stay in a negative State than it
is to push yourself to do the work to
get the thing that you want and and so
it's almost like it's your unrealized
dream showing up in your face and what's
also right in your face is the fact that
somebody else worked for it and you
haven't yet and so instead of going oh
note to self time to start cheering for
myself and use that example as something
positive to motivate myself a lot of
people tend to be like I hate you I hate
you because you have what I have so
here's what you're going to do when you
deal with people that are passive
aggressive or jealous first of all
um don't
don't get triggered by it that's their
stuff it's not your stuff
second
um you're doing the right thing if
people ask share what worked for you
third distance yourself you don't need
to hang out with these people if you're
making positive changes in your life
hang out with the people that are
cheering for you
just because you've known people for
years doesn't mean you have to hang out
with them for the years to come so
distance yourself and fourth if it's
really passive aggressive
um
say something the reason why your life
isn't changing is because your thinking
isn't changing if you wake up every
morning and the first thought in your
head is making yourself wrong why can't
I just get out of bed
why can't I just go exercise why can't I
eat healthy
the reason why
you can't change is because your
thinking is Stopping You Feel the fear
and do it anyway that famous quote I
want to tell you a little bit about the
science so there's this famous
neuroscientist called Antonio dimacio
and he did a really interesting study
where he discovered that our body senses
fear before our mind even realizes it
and when fear or danger
speaking to your boss calling a prospect
going to the gym when you're not proud
of the way that you look
um and you know it's not fear like
Terror it's more that low-grade
agitation in your body I felt it
yesterday because I went to a boot camp
class yesterday and I'm not in good
shape and I don't do boot camp classes
and Kendall and I are staying at this
hotel where holy cow everybody seems
like there's some sort of professional
weight lifter or Instagram model and so
it was really intimidating and I could
feel
that agitation in my body that's the
kind of fear I'm talking about I'm not
talking about the paralysis fear your
life is threatened and you really are in
a life or death situation I'm talking
about the low-grade agitation
that is
um there when you're about to do
something that makes you feel a little
uncomfortable so when fear or danger is
sensed in the body your body begins a
stress response before your mind even
catches up and if you want to take
control of your life you've got to take
control of that physical state and it
starts with catching these moments
everyone
when you
um start to feel it for those of you
that feel very overwhelmed because of
home work side hustle and you're a woman
you probably also feel guilty about
taking time to work on your side hustle
that's because women girls we are raised
to be good girls we're raised to be good
daughters we're raised to be seen and
not heard or raised to take care of
people it's socialized into you and you
see your mothers by the way also
sacrifice everything to take care of
everybody else and to put themselves
laps this is a learned behavior so if
you also are a woman you probably feel
guilty for taking time for yourself stop
that you have to stop that
the reason why you have to stop that is
first of all if you're a mom you've got
to show your daughters and your sons
what it looks like to pursue your dreams
secondly as a woman you're not going to
get what you want if you're constantly
putting guilt on yourself for taking
time for yourself and third the only way
you will discover the power and
potential inside of you is if you push
that generational [ __ ] to the side
and you actually realize that your life
is for you that your mom you know why
she sacrificed everything she did
because she wanted you to pursue your
dreams so knock it off with the guilt
because the guilt is also contributing
to the overwhelm the guilt is making you
not talk to your partner or your boss or
your colleagues or your friends about
what you need for support either guilt
is adding weight to you not being able
to carve out the time and be disciplined
to find the time for yourself and so it
has got to go you hear me get rid of it
isn't it interesting that age is
something that measures the amount of
time that's gone by but don't you have a
lot of baggage about your age you're
either too young or you're too old or
too much time has passed or you blew it
and you wasted your 30s or now that
you're 40 or this or you're only 20. I
mean it's insane how much baggage we all
have about our age and so I'm writing
about how to
remove that story and how to recognize
that whatever time has passed has passed
whether it's a teeny amount of time
because you're just a high school
student or it's a lot amount of time
because you're 60 years old and to
understand that life is an inside game
and it's all about your mindset and it's
all about what you do with the time that
you have right now you can launch
anything you can begin anything period
as long as you are willing to do the
work for it if you're somebody that
suffers from anxiety first of all here's
what you need to know it's not a disease
period it's not a disease here's what
you need to understand
anxiety always begins with a worry
always
it begins with a thought that is
triggered by something so if you suffer
from anxiety you wake up in the morning
and your mind spins you lay in bed at
night and your mind spins you walk into
work and you feel anxious in your body I
want you to write down all the things
that trigger you to feel anxious
interestingly another major trigger is
being home or going home and that moment
right before your partner walks in the
door
if you feel anxious when your partner's
about to walk in or you're about to walk
into your own home that is a major
signal that you're in the wrong
relationship that there is something
incredibly off and you either need to
get into counseling but that is one that
we hear a lot about
because you're walking into a situation
that feels uncertain yeah a lot of
people by the way had parents that were
abusive or parents that were yellers so
they also are experiencing ghosts from
the childhood of its five o'clock dad's
about to come home and pour a drink and
everybody's on edge yeah so write down
the triggers okay because having having
kind of the triggers ahead of time will
help you come up with a plan for how
you're going to catch yourself when your
mind defaults to the automatic ways that
it thinks then what I want you to write
down next to the trigger is what exactly
are you worried about
so having the trigger and then the what
do I worry about I worry that my boss is
going to yell I worry that my partner's
going to yell I worry that I'm going to
get in trouble I worry that
um you know my friends are gonna laugh
at me I worry that I'm going to be a
whatever the [ __ ] it may be then what
you're going to do is you're going to
write down what I call an anchor thought
an anchor thought is something that
weighs you down and it makes you excited
and so here's how the strategy works
with the five second rule the next time
you're in a situation and let's just use
the example of pulling into your own
driveway or your own apartment and maybe
you've got issues with your boyfriend or
girlfriend or your roommate and that
makes you unsettled you're the second
you pull in and you feel the trigger
You're Gonna Go five four three two one
because I want to interrupt your mind
from going into the [ __ ] I don't like
you what if it is and then you're going
to drop in the anchor thought of the
last time that you and your roommate
really got along well
or the last time that you stood up for
yourself and it went fine and you're a
puppy yeah or a puppy or whatever you're
gonna say I'm so excited
to deal with this yeah and then you're
going to get out of your car even though
your body is going to feel a little
unsettled and your mind's gonna race go
54321 if you start to like be like uh
but whatever
and then walk in the door
and what I'm teaching you to do is to
not let your mind hijack you right and
it's very important because there's a
very tight Nexus between
your habit of worrying and spiraling
your thoughts and the way your body
starts to amp up and so we want to
settle your mind so we don't agitate
your body you got it yeah and so if you
start to practice that over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again and for you 18 year olds that are
watching this use this with the nerves
that you have about what you're going to
do with your life use this when you
catch yourself worrying about college
applications because worrying about the
applications won't get them done
worrying about what your friends are
doing won't make it happen worrying
about what you're going to be doing when
you're 25 or how you're going to make
money it's not going to help you make
money right now it's only going to make
you miserable so 54321 cut off that
habit yeah
that'll stabilize your body and then go
to a vision of you at the age of 25
driving a car that you think is cool and
hanging out with a friend that's cool
and saying to yourself I'm so excited
because I know I'm going to figure it
out
because you don't need to worry about
that [ __ ] right now yeah but it becomes
a habit that destroys your year this
year so the holidays are upon us and I
wanted to share my three rules around
the holidays to make sure that even if
you have a very dysfunctional family you
can focus on the fun in Dysfunctional
okay so here are my three rules and
they're all like the three p's of the
holidays okay so you can think about
holiday dinner you don't like to eat
your peas these are the peas that you
want to focus on you ready number one no
politics seriously do not utter anything
about anything related to politics we
live in a crazy polarized whacked out
time right now when it comes to politics
there is no safe topic even if everybody
voted for the same people do not discuss
it that's rule number one no Politics
the second p leave the past in the past
do not dance into Thanksgiving dinner or
any holiday that you're celebrating
during this long season and expect it to
be the moment in time that you're going
to resolve everything that's happened to
you in your past that belongs in a
therapy session or during a long walk in
the woods when you're actually focused
on healing in the past for now you just
want to get along with everybody you
want to have a fun time you don't want
to make this too heavy and you do not
want to be the one bringing the drama to
the table leave that to one of your
uncles or your aunts okay and number
three pretend you care okay no politics
don't heal the past pretend you care
it's not that difficult you don't have
to love everybody you don't have to like
everybody but show up and actually
demonstrate behavior that makes people
feel as if you care what does that mean
it means ask a lot of questions listen
follow up with more questions and you
know the great thing about asking lots
of questions of the folks that are there
at the holidays with you number one it
takes the focus off of you so if you're
worried about talking about where you
are or you aren't in your life ask a lot
of questions you won't be talking about
yourself at all and number two when
other people are talking they think
you're very interesting that's true the
secret to human beings is be interested
because when you're interested in
everybody else suddenly you're the most
interesting person in the room while
they're talking one of the things that
I've learned in my business is that the
mistakes are where all the learning is
and actually the mistakes and the
imperfect stuff that's where the gold is
everybody and so as you're sitting there
and you're thinking about doing stuff
and you're trying to make it perfect and
you're trying to come up with the right
script before you make that cold caller
you're trying to make sure your body
looks perfect before you put yourself
out there on Match you are missing out
on your life period and so I hope that
if there's one thing that I consistently
inspire you to do it's to start before
you're ready it's to put yourself out
there and make mistake it's to have
yourself go live and have it look like
crap and all of a sudden you disconnect
yourself and to be able to laugh at
yourself to be able to shake it off like
that is a skill it's a skill that that
means that you're self-aware it's a
skill that means that you're growing
there's a lot of you that are running
from things
instead of running two things
and that's a huge difference running
from something versus running to
something and so I want you to think
about that for a minute
um because you don't have to move across
country to change your life
and you don't have to do something
drastic to experience drastic positive
change
and here's the thing about running away
from your problems running away from
your past have you ever noticed that
when you run away
it tends to follow you
you know I used to uh have this problem
in relationships and the reason why I
had this problem is because I was a very
unhappy person
I didn't like myself truly as a person
until probably four or five years ago I
spent as sad as this is I spent the
first 46 years of my life really not
liking myself really
um feeling like I wasn't a good person
really questioning the sanity of people
that were in love with me or that were
friends of mine because I had such a low
opinion of myself and it didn't matter
you know I I was guilty not of moving
from one city to another
but I was guilty of moving from one
person to another that I would literally
get in a relationship I would be in a
relationship for a year and then I would
start to feel that unsettled feeling
because what happens after a year of
being in a relationship well you got to
start working on it it's no longer the
thrill and the delight and it's new and
you're dating now it's just you and the
person in your life
there's nothing new about it and so all
your old crap starts to show up and
that's when you got to start to do the
work and so it was about the year or the
year and a half mark in almost every
single relationship that I would start
getting that itchy feeling and the
reason why I was getting that itchy
feeling is because my past was now there
this new relationship was no longer new
and so I was no longer distracted by it
and I was going to have to deal with
myself in order to be happy and so what
did I do for years not even just years
decades everybody I'm not I'm not proud
to admit this but I would literally jump
out of one relationship and into another
new one because another new one would
distract me from the fact that I was an
unhappy person
true story and I think a lot of you who
are unhappy with yourselves are looking
to move jobs or looking to move uh the
city that you live in or you're looking
to change your relationship and the
problem isn't where you live the problem
isn't your job the problem isn't the
person that you're with the problem is
how you feel about yourself if you're
not facing a breakup personally in your
romantic life you still want to pay
attention because somebody that you care
about might be and this is advice that
you can give to them also breakups uh
happen in your career
um you might be breaking up with a work
situation you might be breaking up with
a friend I know a lot of us are working
hard to draw boundaries and to surround
ourselves with more positive people and
we get questions every day about how you
do that and so breaking up with friends
can be just as traumatic as breaking up
with somebody that is a romantic partner
I have three steps to getting over over
a breakup that I'm going to explain in a
minute but first I want to under I want
to explain some research to you to help
you put what you're feeling into context
because what you're going through when
you break up with somebody or you're
broken up with is you literally go
through withdrawal I'm not kidding and
yeah I'm using the word withdrawal where
else do you hear the word withdrawal you
hear the word withdrawal when you hear
about people withdrawing from a drug and
that's a lot uh similar to what you're
going through in fact there was a study
done by neuroscientist Lucy Brown who
found that like drug abuse romantic love
begins with that euphoric feeling it's a
high right and when the drug leaves your
body or the romance leaves your life
what are you left with you're left with
the withdrawal which is a craving for it
validate number one
break breakups are painful but they
don't need to lead you broken so I want
you to validate where you're at it's
great that you're asking the question
you got to have a little bit of
compassion for yourself you got to
understand that you're going to be sad
for a while but please don't pour
gasoline on the sadness fire please
please please don't be staring at photos
of your ex please don't be uh putting
his or her social media face right in
front of your face it's gonna make it
worse but definitely validate the
sadness because you're going through a
major change and it might not be a
change that you wanted number two
separate this is the most important part
because the other thing that I don't
think any of us realize is that when you
get broken off with or you break up with
somebody
you don't realize how much of your daily
routine and the habits that you have and
the way that you go about your day was
tied to the person that you're no longer
with and so what you're not only dealing
with is not only missing the person but
your whole life schedule may have just
been thrown off maybe you two went to
the same gym in the morning maybe you
got a text in the morning from this
person maybe you liked your little
FaceTime call at work maybe your friend
group became their friend group and now
all of a sudden that you're broken up
because you hung out with their friends
all the time you don't have that social
life anymore and so it is so important
for you to recognize that you're not
only facing the person being gone but
the habits that marked your day and the
other people that maybe you hung out
with and the things that you did with
your time and the music that you listen
to and the food that you ate that those
might have all been dictated by the
person you were with and those are
changing too so it's important for you
to separate yourself I think a lot of
women in particular when we get into a
relationship we tend to lose ourselves
we tend to morph into the person that
we're dating I used to do that all the
time and so now we get to the third part
as you start to think about separating
right so you're validating where you're
at you're separating from this person we
need to get to the third part which is
celebrating you
now that you're broken up you have an
opportunity you have an opportunity to
ReDiscover yourself because I guarantee
you you lost a bit of yourself in that
relationship and so as you think about
the way that the structure of your day
has changed what can you proactively
insert that is a celebration of the
things that you stop doing
what have you been keeping yourself from
doing because you were in this
relationship that would celebrate you
who are the friends or family members or
colleagues that really lift you up and
how can you find more time to hang out
with them this is a time to celebrate a
moment when you get to ReDiscover you
I've looked into the research there's
only one habit and skill just one that
has a direct impact on how much money
you make a direct impact on whether or
not you get the promotion and the
influence and the cash money that you
deserve and do you know what that is
any ideas
the one skill the one habit the one
thing that has a meaningful Behavior
change that impacts
what you get
it's your visibility you see you don't
get credit you don't get paid for it and
you don't get graded on the things that
people can't see in order for you to get
what you deserve you have to start being
deliberate about your visibility
behavior that you've got to start
learning to do whether you're shy
whether you're introverted whether
English is your second language it
doesn't matter you've got to learn how
to speak up you've got to learn how to
share your ideas you've got to learn how
to talk about your business you've got
to learn to talk about your dreams and
your goals and I know for many of you
that is one of the most terrifying
things in the world you hate being the
center of attention the idea of speaking
in a meeting at work and risking
sounding like you don't know what you're
talking about is really scary the idea
of asking for feedback from your boss or
asking for a raise really scary the idea
of going in and talking to your
professor about adjusting your grade
really scary the idea of raising your
hand I get it I read your emails I see
the comments but you've got to
understand that this is the number one
skill that you need in order to increase
your visibility wherever it is that you
need to increase your visibility the
world doesn't need another perfect
person the world needs you and you're
trying your best you're doing what you
can and you know I think it's really
important important that you cut
yourself a break
and that you stop thinking that you have
to be perfect there are going to be days
where you're an hour late to pick up
your kid and that's okay there are going
to be days when you can't get to every
email and that's okay there are going to
be days where you feel so underwater and
that's okay you'll get through it you'll
figure it out and you've got to
understand that it's not about being
perfect
it's about just being you and that means
that you got to be willing to start
before you're ready you got to be
willing to do what I do every damn day
which is show up in my rollers or start
a live stream and disconnect myself or
start it and be talking and not even
know that I'm broadcasting you've got to
do that version in your life or you're
not going to get ahead period instead of
doing what so many of us do when we're
broken up with and we go I'm a loser I'm
unlovable I'm not good enough what I
want you to do instead is I want you to
put that opinion and judgment on the
relationship itself that relationship
that's over wasn't good enough wasn't
worthy and wasn't the right fit for love
for you do not take that on as an
internal Judgment of yourself make sure
that when you're judging it you're
judging the relationship and how it
wasn't a good fit for you you my friend
or hole you my friend are perfect how
you are and yeah you may have to change
yeah there's things that you can do
better now that you know better yes
there's baggage you got to deal with but
there's nothing wrong with you there's
just patterns that you need to deal with
you'll get the day where you celebrate
and that was yesterday and
you'll have that moment where you cannot
believe that you actually got into the
school that you wanted or you got the
job that you wanted or you found the
person that that really compliments you
finally or that you got the raise that
you wanted or you built the house that
you've always dreamed of and then a
funny thing happens after you actually
achieve the dream
after you celebrate
life goes right back to the way that it
was
for me what I'm present to is not the
fact that this talk show is actually
happening it's
focused on all the work that I now need
to do in order to do the talk show as
powerfully as I can and I think that the
point that I'm trying to make about the
fact that yeah you can achieve all the
things that you're going for but I've
even noticed already in just 24 hours
like the crazy rise in emotion and
excitement has already been replaced if
things are back to normal that is
exactly what psychologists talk about
when it comes to happiness because happy
is not about achieving things it's not
about getting the result it's about how
you pursue the things that you enjoy and
why you're pursuing them and so the key
to life and I'm seeing it happen in my
own life is not actually checking the
boxes and getting all those things that
you dream about it's how you go about
living your life as you're pursuing it
because if I were just gonna like check
the box and now I'm done biggest goal of
my life to have a daytime talk show just
achieve that Boop
what do I have to look forward to
nothing if you've already achieved it
which is why it's so important for you
to understand that the real meaning of
happiness is about how you show up every
day yes you should have big goals yes
you should have Big Dreams yes yes yes
and yes you should pursue them
I don't ever think that quote making
your dreams come true is what actually
makes you happy because what actually
makes you happy is having those big
dreams and waking up every morning and
doing a little something to push
yourself to make them happen it's about
the pursuit it's really important for
your personal boundaries to use what I
always talk about which is empathy
understand that anybody that's acting
out it doesn't excuse the behavior it
explains it and it also allows you to
separate yourself emotionally that
person is likely miserable that person
has a bad life which is why they treat
people badly and so if you can start to
really use empathy to put it on them
versus making it that they are doing
something to you that can help you from
getting hooked emotionally if you start
Shifting the dynamic and here's how you
do it you do it by being a fan what do I
mean I talk about this all the time if
you Google Mel Robbins being a fan
you'll probably come up with like 10
different videos on YouTube about this
philosophy it's a philosophy about
leading with a pre appreciation it's a
philosophy about cheering for other
people publicly because what happens
when you cheer for other people
is you naturally trigger the law of
reciprocity and even the biggest jerk
face even the biggest curmudgeon even
the biggest most competitive person on
the planet who might be competitive by
the way because she's paying for her
parents
nursing home bill and she's feeling
stressed out and she's also divorced I
mean who knows what's driving this
competitive nature maybe it's a sense of
scarcity and fear and insecurity and so
the opposite of competition isn't more
competition it's connection
and you create Connection by cheering
for people the majority of people lack
self-awareness at work
you get that the person who's
disrespecting you likely doesn't even
know what they're doing
the person who's taking his or her anger
out on you likely doesn't know how it's
impacting you you see when people do
this when they have these kind of toxic
patterns they've been getting away with
them for so long because nobody has had
the courage to cross-check them verbally
on it and that's where you come in lucky
you you're in their life because your
purpose in their life is to be the one
person that has the courage to actually
sit down and have a candid conversation
about it so what are you going to do how
do you have that candid conversation
first of all try not to make them wrong
try not to come in and shame them and
tell them all the horrible things
they're doing because you'll immediately
create a situation where they're
defensive and if the research Bears out
from Harvard Business School and they
actually had no idea that they were
doing it they might get defensive the
better way to do it the more effective
way to do it is to explain how their
behavior impacts you
and when you do that most people are
mortified because most people are
venting or are disrespectful and they're
not even thinking about the impact it
has because nobody's ever told them
gotta raise your own game and so what is
the game that you play at work you got
to get out of the head that it's all
about you
the best team members are always
thinking about how to make the team
better the best team members are loyal
to the team the best people to work with
are the ones that are in it together and
so in order for you to get your toxic
colleague to shift Behavior you gotta
model it and here's the interesting
thing about the research when people are
working with co-workers or on a team
where people collaborate and where you
have honest conversations it creates
what we call psychological safety which
basically just means I feel safe working
with you I know that if I come to you
with feedback you listen I know that if
I tell you how your behavior is
impacting me you'll actually care I know
that if you need help you'll come to me
and I know if I need help I can come to
you that's what psychological safety
means you're a safe person and hopefully
a fun person to work with so you've got
to model that that means you got to ask
for support that means you got to have
direct collaborate or direct
conversations and it means you got to
support your team members too and do you
realize that when you work with other
people that do this team members are 35
times more likely to show visible
commitment to your success and they're
47 more likely when you model it to work
hard to build and maintain your trust
so don't ever get resigned in thinking
that the way that you behave won't
impact how somebody else is behaving
around you one of the most important
things when you're in a situation where
the truth the facts are that there is
more on your plate than one human being
can effectively handle on his or her own
there's a really important moment where
you have to surrender
to the chaos that your life is for the
next couple weeks things are going to
change when summer hits
but part of what I find personally
is that when I resist and I do resist I
resist what's actually happening when
that's not the way that I want things to
go and so if you start complaining or
you start bringing extra weight to all
of the things that are going on it's
gonna make it feel even more
overwhelming and if you can bring a
sense of realism to it so I call this
and I think Sean anchors the one that
came up with this this this term
realistic optimism
realistic optimism is a really powerful
mindset because
you're not just putting a sunny spin on
a crappy situation
you're being realistic about where you
are in your life right now
and you are still
maintaining an optimistic point of view
and what that means is that you when
you're an optimist you believe that your
actions and your thoughts matter
you believe that you can handle what's
on your plate you believe that based on
your thoughts and your actions you can
positively affect the outcome of
whatever it is that you're dealing with
whether it's being wildly overwhelmed
because you're a single parent or
terrified because you just got a scary
Health diagnosis or you're spinning
because somebody just told you they
don't want to be in a relationship with
you anymore whatever it is that you're
facing that's making you feel
overwhelmed
first start with how important it is to
be a realistic optimist so there's a
surrendering to what's so but you're
going to stay very optimistic and
positive and know that everything that
you think and do is in your control and
that when you know that your behavior
matters it gives you a sense of
empowerment that's proven by research
super duper important it's also why you
can have a very hard life right now and
a very overwhelming life right now and
still be happy
because you know based on being a
realistic Optimist that this period will
pass and you know that there are things
that you can think about and do that are
within your control all oftentimes when
you hit bottom you bounce
and that's where I think the power is
that you when the world feels upside
down you always have the power to make
it right when one chapter ends you
always have the power to write a new one
when you know you feel like nobody loves
you you have the power to learn how to
love yourself and if there's one thing
that covid-19 has done regardless of
whatever Devastation it has caused in
your life is it has forced us all to
experience the great pause
and I read that in a medium article and
I loved that idea of a pause because I
think in 2020 our lives have gotten so
fast and so digital and when you are
forced to pause and get present and to
slow down you are reminded of what's
actually important
and what's important is your health
what's important is your family and your
friends what's important is whether or
not you are taking care of yourself and
thinking positive thoughts versus
negative thoughts the world gave us a
gigantic experiment where we got to
practice and get to continue to practice
the most important skill in the planet
which is emotional resilience the
ability to face hard
and actually be okay the ability to face
the uncertain and redirect your
attention on things that you know that
are certain as is the case in life
you're always going to be growing and
when you hit new chapters in your life
it's really important to be deliberate
and mindful about the people that you
spend time with and who you surround
yourself with does that mean you got to
ditch your high school friends
absolutely not
but it might mean that you shouldn't
spend as much time with them it might
mean that you should show up to those
friendships a little bit differently and
maybe they'll go a little bit deeper and
it definitely means that based on where
you are in your life right now that you
should get more proactive about
surrounding yourself with a group of new
friends or current friends that are up
to the same kind of growth that you are
why do you think that is in human beings
that you know things are going bad we
won't change if they're going good we
won't change but it's almost like we
need a massive breakdown near-death
experience divorce covid for us to see
clearly to start changing well there's a
really simple answer patterns
so the thing about all human beings is
that we are pattern learning machines
and if you feel stuck or broken I
guarantee you while you feel that way
you're not you have a pattern of
behavior or a pattern of thinking that
is broken
we need
to be disrupted
because we love our patterns and even
people that I know like in pain even
when we're in pain we love it Pain's
familiar for a lot of people yeah so a
lot of people like you may be listening
to Lewis and I talking and you grew up
in a super chaotic household maybe your
parents argued all the time maybe your
Dad or Mom were in and out maybe there
was a lot of fighting maybe there was
actual abuse I don't know what was going
on but it was chaotic as hell and so as
an adult you have valid yourself you're
not going to repeat that pattern but
what ends up happening is because as a
little kid you observed witness absorbed
the pattern of Chaos in your nervous
system
unless you go about the intentional work
of breaking the pattern of chaos you
will create it in your own life because
it's what's familiar
you won't understand why do I keep
dating these why do I why do I go to
these bosses that treat me like crap
because you don't know what it feels
like
to be in a relationship with either a
boss or a romantic partner or a roommate
that is consistent because for the first
18 years of your life you lived in a
state called when's the next shoe going
to drop right and so wherever it is in
your life that something is broken there
is a pattern That You Don't See yet that
is making you continue to stay in a
broken situation and it's all that
thinking that overthinking that thinking
too big thinking big is about dreams
thinking big is about goals thinking big
is about your heart and your soul and
figuring out what you want then once you
do that and you think big and you see
where you're headed boom you got to come
back and you got to go Brick by Brick to
make that Vision stick you got to go
Brick by Brick to make the action stick
you got to go Brick by Brick to lay that
pathway forward and to keep going and
let me tell you something I don't care
how busy you are I don't care how tired
you are I don't care how much there is
to do to make this big dream forward you
have time to lay one brick a day you
really do you really do and this is the
secret everybody this is the secret to
everything it's to understanding that
there is no timeline to getting your
dreams done
all there is to do is to allow your
heart and soul to dream big to see the
path forward and then to pull yourself
into the moment every day and have the
discipline to be deliberate to lay one
brick on that path that's it and to keep
reminding yourself that everything that
you're learning on the way is you lie
bricks down and you move forward a
little at a time is helping you build
the path and there will be times that
you start to lay bricks in this
direction and you realize whoa wait a
minute I'm going over here and my dream
is over there I guess I better lay
bricks over here and head back in the
direction then you're gonna go this way
that's great because everything that you
learned over here is going to be exactly
what you needed in order to be
doing what your big dream is having a
breakdown is one of the biggest things
on the planet because what you get is
you get a break from your own [ __ ]
and you can look objectively at where
you are and for the first time look
ahead and say well what do I want to go
create and nine times out of ten if
you're discouraged right now if you've
got Financial Devastation if you've if
you're facing something that is making
this moment in time as hard for you as
life was for Lewis and I in 2008 during
the last recession I beg you
ask yourself honestly if what you had is
actually what you wanted the thing that
you just lost that that job that you
bushed about all the time a relationship
that was yeah to you yeah yes or the
friends you can't hang out with because
it's convenient and you can't you're in
quarantine like actually ask yourself if
this is what you wanted or were you just
used to it um
being used to something Louis I think is
the biggest reason why people don't
change
I asked my mother I love my mother I
love my parents I've been married 51
years which is a feat because they were
my mom was a Teen Mom but
uh I asked her once if she'd go to a
personal development seminar with me
what'd you say
are you [ __ ] kidding me
why would I want to change at my age oh
wow I might discover I hate my life
wow
I was like okay I'm just gonna leave
that right there and I always talk about
how you have the power in your life
always I know that you may have your
feelings hurt I know you may be angry or
upset or frustrated I certainly feel
those things all the time in my life but
I want you to understand that no matter
what's going on you always have the
power because you can choose what you
think and what you do next
you may not be able to control the way
that somebody treated you but you may
not be able to control uh the number of
promotions that have passed you by you
may not be able to control whether or
not your boss is a jerk face or not to
you but you can choose how you respond
to these things and that's where your
power is this is a very important first
piece of advice by the way is that a lot
of times we start to feel the weight of
the overwhelm but we don't get out of
our heads and if you spend too much time
thinking about all the stuff that's
going on and you don't go through the
process of breaking it down and figuring
out what actually is important to you
and prioritizing what you're going to do
about it you're just going to continue
to feel heavier and heavier and heavier
it's more and more sunk I mean it's it's
very very difficult thing to feel why
don't you like the size you are
is it yes okay because I don't believe
in losing weight to be skinny I believe
in getting healthy because of how it
makes you feel yeah so if you love the
size that you are and it's healthy you
should stay the size that you are but
if you look in the mirror
and seeing your body the size that it is
gives you evidence to say I'm a piece of
[ __ ] or I'm unworthy what do you say to
yourself when you see yourself in the
mirror like all of those things tell me
what is it let's get it out of your head
and let's bring it to the light because
you know you feel comfortable saying
this to yourself
when you're alone don't you I want you
to say it out loud because it's it's not
okay to say this stuff to yourself what
do you say to yourself that we're not
going to say anymore
I'm disgusting what else
I hate the way that I look I hate the
way I feel I hate the way that I feel
okay what do you want what do you
deserve to feel good when they walk down
the street yes yes you do see I think at
the heart of this I think at the heart
of this is a belief
that you don't deserve to feel that way
so who taught you to feel them that you
don't deserve it when did you start
saying that to yourself that you don't
deserve it Holly maybe when I was like
six or seven that's usually when it
happens so what I want you to do is I
want you to leave here and what you're
going to go to war against is not your
weight you're going to go to war against
the pattern in your head okay because
the longer you invalidate yourself the
less motivated you're going to be to
change yeah because you're beating
yourself down so we got to start with
not texting you you're not broken you're
perfect how you are Ollie you are
I know you don't feel that way but I
feel that way yeah it's the pattern up
here that's broken yeah so we just want
you to have a zero tolerance policy for
this like I'm not worth it I don't
deserve it I'm a piece of this I'm all
that no 54321 it's like an ax you got
that and then you're gonna come up what
can we say instead
this I do that I can do this but more
important I think it needs to be more
heart centered I deserve to feel good
yeah I deserve to have what I want watch
me go get it my own mind because it's
not something I'm used to yet is making
up stories to cling to the old way of
life this is a moment in time everyone
please
this is the greatest gift the greatest
gift is this moment of pause where you
get in touch with what you actually want
and if you don't have the skills
for crying out loud look around and take
an online course because if you need
skills to prepare yourself for the thing
that you want get them right now when
you hit a moment in your life or your
work or your family where you feel very
overwhelmed
one of the most important things to not
do is to not speed up
I tend to be the kind of person that
when I get overwhelmed or I feel the way
to the World on my shoulders or I feel
stuck I tend to start running into a
brick roll head first at about 50 miles
an hour
that is exactly what you should not do
you should slow down
you should slow down and you should
assess where you are and you should
bring that realistic optimism
to doing some problem solving and some
planning and some decluttering in your
very busy life in four through four main
categories okay it's so important that
you slow down and realize that part of
the overwhelm is coming from the fact
that you are too busy there is too much
on your plate there's probably a lot on
your plate that's the wrong things there
are probably things that you're thinking
about that are not important and that's
why once you slow down you also start to
think about being a realistic Optimist
you also need to declutter and that's
where your friend Mel Robbins comes in
setting a quitting time isn't something
that I invented it's something I stole
from a professor at Caltech and the the
setting and quitting time habit is so
important it leverages something called
Parkinson's law Parkinson's law is a
phenomenon around time that basically
says this
anything that you have to get done you
will get done in the amount of time that
you give to it so let me just ask you
this if you think about your to-do list
if you have 10 hours today to work on it
how long is it going to take you to get
through it 10 hours if you have 10
minutes to get through the to-do list
that you have how long is it going to
take you 10 minutes because the things
you need to do expand or contract
according to how much time you have to
give to it and so what I want you to do
right now because part of your problem
with your routine is you don't have one
you allow work to bleed into your
evening you allow work to just
constantly show up whenever the email
arrives and you're the one that has to
hit reset on your routine so that you
don't allow your work to do that when a
manager or a boss defines Norms the team
is 73 times more likely to work hard to
keep them and here's the kicker there
are 125 times more likely to address the
situation if there's somebody on the
team who is not operating within the
norms
you know I I it's it's so obvious I mean
think about it if somebody were to walk
in
to work
and uh put their feet up on the desk and
turn on porn
and be sitting at their desk watching
porn would that be the norm
for your workplace I don't think so
unless you're working for Playboy or
you're working in the porn industry that
would be so out of the norm that
everybody would address it immediately
period full stop and what I want you to
understand is that when you take
responsibility for how you're acting on
the team and you're collaborative and
you're supportive and you're putting the
team first and you're modeling that
behavior and when you also bring the
courage and you dare as brene Brown says
to be brave enough to have honest
conversations with your colleagues about
what's acceptable and what's not based
on how things are impacting you you
personally shift the culture in a
positive direction now here's a trick
about gratitude writing down what you're
grateful for doesn't work unless you do
it this way because if you if I ask you
what you're grateful for everybody says
the same thing I'm grateful to be alive
I'm grateful for my health and I'm
grateful for my family and that's so
generic that you're not retraining your
brain right you've got to add in the
because
I'm grateful for X because and the added
detail will make you change up
what you say and it will also train your
mind in a way that's more detailed so it
actually has a lasting impact on the way
that you view the world
to identify and for me as a kid for
whatever reason I have my own version of
feeling invisible and feeling like I'm
not good enough and so my way of coping
both with my anxiety and being a
survivor of sexual abuse and
um
and wanting love which we all need is I
was like an overachiever and so I'm the
kind of person that's super busy and a
go-getter because it got me attention
and if I was the one that was super busy
and achieving I not only got praise but
it also insulates you from other people
not picking you because you're the one
in a leadership role doing the picking
right and so there's a part of me at the
age of 51 that is realizing that you
know this these feelings of feeling
unworthy and this hyper drive to try to
achieve it's all coming from a place of
feeling inadequate or like what I'm
doing is not enough and so that's 50
having a talk show having a best-selling
book having the audible Originals having
the platform everywhere having the
impact is still don't feel being the
most booked female speaker in the world
like you still don't feel so stupid it's
annoying and human beings are annoying
we are stuck with this wiring like if
you think about it like all of the crap
you believe is probably a hangover from
age zero to ten
that as adults we walk around thinking
the same stuff we thought as kids and I
can't stand that I feel that way but
knowing it it allows me to catch it
before it has me before it stops me from
having an event or writing that next
book or taking a risk here's the thing
about morning routines I think morning
routine Envy is a real thing and I do
believe that a lot of people lie about
their morning routines I think lying
about your morning routine is a real
thing I think pretending you have the
perfect morning routine is a real thing
I'm
I'm about when I'm home I'm almost 80 in
my morning routine I get it done because
it's super simple right so I mean I
think I need a simple one yes and when
I'm traveling
I almost never get the whole thing done
because there's too many excuses I think
the key to having a morning routine and
morning routines are critical because
how you start your day
has a massive proven impact on how your
day turns out there's one piece of
research that I think is really profound
and this comes from Sean anchor I talked
about this yesterday but I'm going to
tell you
um this too Susie if you consume three
minutes just three minutes of negative
news
of negative television of negative
emails maybe stressful emails from work
or stressful texts from friends you have
more than a 50 chance eight hours later
to say you had a bad day
and the reason why is because of what
consuming that kind of information does
to your mind it literally sets your mind
up to be on the lookout for things going
wrong and so the reason why a morning
routine is is actually so important is
because number one it determines what
your priority for the day is and we also
know based on Research that your mood in
the morning it impacts your productivity
all day long everything that I have done
since since we launched the five second
rule book was in reaction to things that
were coming to me
so I never sat out and said hey the five
second rule audiobook has been a
complete uh like record breaker we
clearly have an audio audience let's go
pitch audible audible came to me which
is fantastic
um I never I always dreamed about having
a talk show but I wasn't out pitching
one
Sony came to me in fact the only reason
why we got into courses online courses
and we now have more than a half a
million people that have taken our
courses online
um
was because Success magazine came to me
and said let's do a course together
remember I was there to view you for it
oh and I was I hated it because what I
discovered is I hate being told what to
do and so but that gave me the idea oh
we should do courses ourselves and so
this pauses made me stop and go what do
I really want to do
and the the truth is I want to go and
make the biggest possible impact that I
can and I want to collaborate with more
people and I want to do events
um and I
I don't want to be the CEO I'm a
terrible leader horrible leader the
worst actually
um because I'm amazing at coaching I'm
amazing at uh creating I'm amazing at
reacting I'm terrible at managing people
I am terrible at managing a project I
have ADD I have dyslexia
um I'm a bulldozer when I get anxious
um
we kill each other if we were roommates
or business partners but but I think
understanding yourself
is really important and so there's a
couple things that I've decided number
one I'm going to consciously create the
next chapter and what is that and I'm
um well I'm still in the middle of doing
it yeah but you're one of the events you
want to do these things you're talking
about yeah yes and I wanna I wanna
collaborate more with a wider audience
of people um and I want to build a brand
bigger than Mel Robbins yep I don't want
it to just be me I want to build a
platform based business that uh reaches
more people because here's the thing
that has got that got me through kind of
the loss of the talk show and the way
that I think about things that I hope
helps
um if you're listening yeah you're kind
of struggling with something
um I believe and I went into the talk
show saying this to myself because
there's a 99 chance based on the history
of people that have tried to have a
daytime talk show that was going to fail
and I went in there saying
this I'm not doing this because I expect
to have a successful talk show I'm going
to put a thousand percent into it so
that I have no regrets and I wouldn't
change a thing but I'm going into this
because I know that there is a skill a
person or an experience I am meant to
have
that will help me
for the next chapter that I can't see
coming one thing that's true about life
is that things are always changing
around you always whether you are moving
into a new season or in in school and
all of a sudden your kids school
schedules change or you're moving into a
new season of work and all of a sudden
your work life is changing or you're
moving into a new season of your
marriage or of your health or of
anything life changes all the time which
is why it's really important to be
self-aware and to make the small changes
that help you enjoy and seize all the
opportunities from the season of Life
work family relationships that you're in
right now the only thing that you can do
do is change yourself for the better and
Hope
that that means that when you change for
the better
that your friends and the people that
you love and care about are inspired
and encourage change for the better too
and if you have people in your life that
are stuck they probably are all resigned
they don't believe that their behavior
can change this they don't believe that
their attitude can change this maybe
they're feeling a little beaten down
part of the self-awareness and
self-mastery and the ability to move
your life forward is not only in 54321
finding the instant motivation and
courage to push yourself forward but the
true Liberation and freedom is going to
come when you start to understand
the body signals that got programmed a
long time ago a long time ago in your
body
that are holding you back and learning
how in those moments when you get a pit
in your stomach to recognize it and slow
The Body Sensations down and then move
forward before your mind starts talking
you out of it so a lot of what happens
for us is you had situations when you
were a kid maybe your mom or your dad
were really intense maybe you grew up in
a very competitive household maybe you
um were the kind of kid that things were
better in your house when you were seen
but not heard and so any and your body
remembers it your body remembers
situations when your parents were
yelling because as a kid it feels
traumatic your body remembers situations
where in a classroom you were nervous or
afraid to be called out or be seen your
body remembers moments when you were
embarrassed and so what's interesting is
that
um
your body will now face any situation
where you're about to be seen or you're
about to speak up or you're about to do
something where you're facing
uncertainty or you're about to
um face judgment and your body remembers
those situations and it starts to get
nervous or agitated or on edge because
it knows oh my God you're about to do
something that's going to expose you and
your body wants to keep you safe that's
why your stomach starts to go grumbly
that's why your chest starts to get
tight because you are about to do
something that exposes you you're about
to do something that is new you're about
to do something that is scary and your
body wants to try to protect you now
your body's misreading the situation by
the way because you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to see my recent interview with
Mel Robbins one on one check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there I hope your business goes
bankrupt Evan Evan you're a terrible
person I spent the first
40 some years of my life trying to be
somebody else I'll give you guys a
secret way